non
bonsoir temps orageux hier soir à
l'assemblée nationale pierre bérégovoy
aurait été contraint de démissionner si
la motion de censure avait recueilli
trois petites voix de plus temps lourd
au sénat cet après midi charles pasqua
notre invité ce soir bonsoir monsieur
pasqua défend bec et ongles son idée de
la france contre les partisans de
l'europe nombreux au palais du
luxembourg temps un certain brio le
sommet de la terre sur l'environnement
s'ouvrira demain sur fond de divergences
entre le nord et le sud
temps capricieux à roland garros la
pluie la vraie joue des tours aux
organisateurs des internationaux de
france
mais elle a bien voulu s'arrêter en fin
d'après midi dominique champeau oui
j'ajouterai sale temps pour le croate
ivan is heavy tx qui a perdu la première
manche 6 2 qui est menée 4 à 0 dans la
deuxième et qui s'il défend chèrement sa
chance ici dans le 5e jeu de la deuxième
manche au réveil un petit peu tard il a
d'énormes qualités
goran ivanisevic mais jim courir là un
peu usés au mental c'est son point
faible aux croates
et dès qu'ils ne jouent pas parfaitement
comme il le voudrait
eh bien ils décrochent des partis c'est
ce qui permet à jim courir qui est
impitoyable depuis le début de cette
quinzaine de roland garros de mener
assez nettement maintenant dans cette
rue évidemment vous retrouvera dominique
à la fin de ce journal on reviendra sur
les qualifications des demoiselles
rappelez-nous leur nom celles qui sont
qualifiés aujourd'hui alors les quatre
principales têtes de série sont
qualifiés donc pour les demi finales il
s'agit de mesdemoiselles céleste graff
arantxa
sanchez et gabriela non j'en ai oublié
une sabbatique et la sabatiera voilà on
vous retrouve de toute façon peu avant
20h michel tour et nous le disait dès
19h le sud va souffrir des orages dans
les heures qui viennent la grêle
pourraient même tomber sur certains
départements et malheureusement elle
accentuera les dégâts déjà importants
comme dans le lot-et-garonne reportage
de xavier giroudot et jean-pierre d'art
ou 48 heures après l'orage les gros l'on
demeure témoignage du déluge
le soleil revenu est clair un spectacle
de désolation chez les agriculteurs
l'état de choc a fait place à
l'inquiétude
je ne sais pas comment on va faire
il en faudra voir avec les banquiers et
tout ça et leur faudra voir comment on
va s'en sortir
après le manque d'eau il y a deux ans le
gel l'an dernier voilà le lot et garonne
à nouveau sinistre et les cultures
détruites à 100% par endroits augure
d'une récolte quasi nulle cette année
les agriculteurs doivent attendre que la
commune soit déclarée zone sinistrée
pour toucher des indemnités
en attendant il faut parer au plus
pressé pour certains l'heure est aux
licenciements et à la vente peut pas
garder personnel je suis en plein
le faire partir quatre saisonniers la
dengue et quatre autres fin de semaine
si je trouve avant tout et surtout on le
prie qu'on peut vendre parce qu'avant
depuis 88 on ne peut pas avoir que des
problèmes au parquet ce qu'on peut
récupérer à lagarrigue
on s'est remis au travail oubliant ce
caprice du ciel une contrariété du leur
qui a réduit à néant une année de labeur
raymond barre est toujours dans
l'opposition mais il n'a pas voté la
motion de censure déposée par son camp
hier sur la politique agricole du
gouvernement pierre de bénouville et
toujours dans l'opposition mais il n'a
pas lui non plus voter la motion de
censure
ernest moutoussamy est apparenté
communiste mais il n'a pas suivi les
consignes de vote d'andré lajaunie est
bien pierre bérégovoy peut envoyer un
beau bouquet de roses à ces trois hommes
atypique qui l'ont tout simplement sauvé
sans eux il démissionner jean baptiste
auprès d'ali en première ligne hier soir
pour le vote de la peau sur les députés
rpr mais sur 126 2 ne participeront pas
au défilé
alain peyrefitte après un malentendu et
surtout pierre de bénouville pierre de
bénouville 77 ans élu gaulliste depuis
cinquante et un ancien bras droit de
marcel dassault
mes amis d'enfance de françois
mitterrand au rpr on est formel aux
prochaines élections il n'aura pas
l'investiture du mouvement deuxième
absent de marque la seule défection des
40 centriste
raymond barre invisible hier mais
présent aujourd'hui à la réunion de son
groupe
plus que jamais indépendant libre de ces
votes comme de ces censures même si on
lui oppose en 93 un candidat rpr udf de
défection deux ombres au tableau d'une
censure presque abouti hier soir après
les menaces l'opposition préféré
minimiser la politique c'est ainsi et
c'est un courant média mais il voit
parfois vous perdez à deux voies je
crois que c'est réellement un
avertissement très grave pour le
gouvernement
avertissements rythme éthique et
politique pierre bérégovoy sauvé à trois
voies dont deux de francs tireurs de
l'opposition
de quoi vérifier le sens des mots
majorité relative charles pasqua re
bonsoir bonsoir pierre de bénouville et
toujours et repère à posieux tous les
cahiers toujours gaulliste comment
expliquez-vous ce vol je ne sais pas
peut-être pour des raisons personnelles
mais ce qu'il ya de certain c'est que
quelles que soient les raisons pour
lesquelles un certain nombre de nos amis
qu'ils soient rpr udf ne suive pas les
consignes de leur groupe
c'est difficilement acceptable raymond
varrault mettre un terme à l'équivoque
raymond badiou dans l'opposition vous
demandez le lui mais en ce qui me
concerne je crois qu'il est beaucoup
plus proche d'une entente avec rendre
sur midrand que d'autre chose il faut
que les choses soient claires aux yeux
des français profite d'ailleurs c'est
françois mitterrand qui disait
l'opposition doit être totale ou elle
n'est pas moi j'ai plutôt tendance et un
trône opposant résolu au total
alors à ce deuxième c'est pas dans l'est
dans ce genre de phase iib si les deux
mitaine alors regardons avant de
poursuivre ce qui s'est passé cet après
midi au sénat avec michel lemaire les
alain thomas je ne forcerai pas la main
au sénat prévient d'emblée et pierre
bérégovoy
illustration d'une atmosphère très
conforme à l'image de la haute assemblée
un débat courtois dans la forme mais où
rien d'essentiel n'est concédé sur le
fond le droit de vote des européens est
naturellement au centre de la discussion
la commission des lois avait proposé que
ce droit soit présentée comme une
possibilité et non une obligation
réponse sans ambiguïté le traité houbre
avec des garanties un droit effectif
pas un droit virtuel refuser le droit de
vote et l'éligibilité c'est rejeter le
traité ce et des girls intentions de
ceux qui ont proposé ce refus charles
pasqua mène la charge pour repousser le
texte sur le droit de vote et contre
tout ce qui peut ressembler à un abandon
de souveraineté mais c'est dans les
rangs mêmes de l'opposition que lui
vient la réponse je me demande si vous
le voulez bien vers vous monsieur le
président du groupe rpr il ne s'agit pas
pour la france d'appliquer ou à que ce
soit de sa souveraineté au profit d'une
communauté supranationale il s'agit bien
au contraire à nos yeux cette aumône de
re conquérir au moins partiellement et
le plus possible une souveraineté qui
nous échappe de plus en plus des la nuit
sera longue au palais du luxembourg
une cinquantaine d'orateurs sont
inscrits dans ce débat charles pasqua
vous êtes déçu de ne pas être suivi par
toute l'opposition qui est majoritaire
au sénat je le rappelle sur le droit de
vote des européens que vous ne voulez
pas l'important ce n'est pas d'être
suivi ou pas l'important c'est de dire
ce que l'on croit et de faire ce que
l'on ce que l'on pense
conforme à l'intérêt général je crois
qu'un certain nombre de nos amis de
l'opposition d'au moins certains qui se
prépare à donner le droit de vote
ressortissants de la communauté ne se
rendent pas tout à fait content de ce
qui nous attend ce qui nous attend c'est
l'abandon des principes fondamentaux de
la république qui sont ceux qui ont
permis la constitution de cette nation
depuis deux siècles et d'autre part il
est bien évident qu'à partir du moment
où on aura ouvert cette brèche
quelles que soient les garanties
supposer que l'on se donnerait on aurait
deux conséquences
la première on s'en remettrait à la cour
de justice européenne pour des
différentes éventuelles c'est pas le
conseil constitutionnel qui jugera s'il
y a une différente on sentit sens de la
communauté qui se retrouveraient brimés
par certaines disposent
sur notre droit c'est la cour de justice
européenne qui serait amené à juger
respecte le président lecanu et pour
lequel j'ai beaucoup d'amitié mais
l'amitié à la dépense en cause ce sont
les fondements mêmes de la république
sur ses fondements
on ne peut pas transiger en ce qui me
concerne je ne transigerai pas mon
groupe non plus alors votre propos
l'illustrent vous menez votre combat
avec force avec clarté
il ya un mystère la rue main que nous
rapporte arlette chabot nous dit que
vous apprêtez à abandonner la présidence
du groupe rpr comment mener un combat
est abandonnée en même temps un pot
soutient pourtant je ne suis pas du tout
décidés à bandol et la prise en europe
et repère pour le moment est la rentrée
j'ai dit à mes collègues que c'est
évident j'ai dit à mes collègues parce
que je leur dois que à la rentrée bien
il faudra me trouver un successeur à la
présidence du groupe rpr du sénat
pourquoi il y aura bientôt 10 ans que
j'occupe ce poste
je crois qu'il est normal de donner la
plaque de laisser la place à d'autres
ça ne veut pas dire pour autant vous
l'imaginez bien ça ne veut pas dire pour
autant que j'ai l'intention de déserter
le combat politique
alors ils ont d'autre part il faut c'est
une présidence nous en présente pas il
faut être conscient on ne peut pas
vouloir une chose et son contraire
je suis un peu excédé par ce qu'ils
disent
charles pasqua fait recaler à présent au
sénat est votre candidat ceci va être
candidat cela on peut on peut dire que
si on peut dire les moyens pour leur
côté soyons sérieux en tout les 4 je
veux dire ceci je ne roule pas pour moi
je défends les idées auxquelles je crois
je verrai bien le moment venu ce que je
dois faire ce qui est certain c'est que
je suis attachée au mouvement qu'elle
j'appartiens que je souhaite qu'il soit
aussi fort que possible qu'ils
s'expriment clairement et que nous
perdions le moins de temps possible en
conciliabule avec nos partenaires parce
qu'on défend mieux ses idées quand on
est à la tête et pas dans le rang je ne
serai jamais dans laurent vous le savez
bien
quel que soit le poste que j'occuperai
beaucoup de gens écouteront ce que je
dis je suis convaincu vous allez vous
présenter aux primaires de l'opposition
pour les présidentielles je me
présenterai aux premiers rangs de
l'opposition
si les idées auxquelles je crois n'était
pas représenté par quelqu'un mais il
nous avons ré que c'est une hypothèse
hautement improbable
ou justement c'est ce que vous faites en
ce moment sonne comme un reproche à
l'égard de jacques chirac à l'égard non
certains à l'égard des tic et quand je
reproche je le fais monsieur amar je le
fait de reproche à personne quand le
moment du combat arrive il faut sonner
la charge pour que les gens sont alors
avant de sonner la charge à 3,25
c'est ce que j'ai fait j'ai publié un
livre qui s'appelle l'art de renouvelle
c'était dans la veille de 86 nous sommes
en 92 et en 93 il ya des élections
elle a juste moyen 92 vous publiez un
livre charles pasqua que demande le
peuple
publié par albin michel alors évidemment
c'est une critique sévère cité et non
payées non pour la culture on peut les
faire pour ce genre de livre on peut le
faire
d'accord que demande le peuple critiques
sévères contre le pouvoir mais auto
critique aussi auto critique à propos
des hommes publics vous dites c'est un
échec sur ce que demande le peuple c'est
à dire l'éducation la santé vous dites
est un échec
je crois oui mais c'est vous l'avez dit
vous-même vous avez commencé par dire
une autocritique
je ne me contente pas de critiquer les
autres je me sens moi-même responsable
et je me sens donc dans une certaine
mesure également coupable et j'essaie de
dire à mes collègues
réveillons nous parlons de l'essentiel
répondre notre peuple sur les problèmes
qui le concerne
que devons nous faire pour la sécurité
pour l'éducation pour lutter contre le
chômage etc
je doive quelques idées et je crois que
si on écoutait davantage notre peuple il
est plein de bon sens on se porterait
mieux donc vous ne serez plus président
vers 40e et on vous retrouve quand même
du jamais été président du rpr du groupe
mr au sénat de perdre le mot là dessus
c'était intéressant
j'aurai toujours la nature album merci
sur moi pour être de toute façon au
premier rang merci charles pasqua au
danemark ce sont les citoyens même
qu'ils donnent leur avis sur maastricht
le résultat du référendum sera connue
tout à l'heure mais les sondages vont
tous dans le même sens le oui
l'emporterait de justesse
reportage de jean paul girouard et avec
une en être ou ne pas en être
c'est bien au danemark mais ça n'est pas
hamlet la question posée à quatre
millions d'électeurs forte sur leur
volonté d'adhérer
nouvelle forme d'europe celle de match
dans le stade de l'école de new browser
la classe moyenne du quartier a remplacé
les collégiens à la sortie des urnes
pessimisme chez ceux qui ont voté nay
non chez les partisans de maastricht
confiant si votre épaule et nos mais
j'ai peur qu'elle est non il ne va pas
gagner quand ce sera sérieux pour les
danois
il ils vont toujours réfléchir pour
l'économie je pense que l'économie se
sera pour beaucoup mieux si on reste
dans le marché commun et pour nous c'est
le oui et non c'est pour rester dans le
marché commun et c'est trop cher que je
pense que oui 20 ans portait apparemment
un vote de raison économique plus qu'un
choix du coeur pourtant la participation
est très forte les chants ont voté plus
coquins lié à les champenoises
apparemment n'était pas seule europe 1
sarah seppuku elle est un droit qu'ils
soient pour ou contre maastricht les
danois s'accorde sur au moins une chose
leur satisfaction d'avoir voté de
pouvoir choisir eux-mêmes le destin
européen ou non de leur pays ici le
fonctionnement de la démocratie la
marche de l'europe l'identité danoise
sondés sujet si sensible qu'il aurait
très mal supporté que l'on décide 11 au
cambodge nous vous le disions et hier
les habitants se remettent difficilement
de la déchirure
ils se sont réconciliés avec la
bénédiction de l'onu mais le risque
d'affrontement demeurent les milices
n'ont pas vraiment disparu et elle sont
armés reportage de pierre babey et
marque doux de l'autre côté de la
barrière
le vietnam cette frontière ne doit
laisser passer que le petit trafic local
et se fermer hermétiquement au trou et
aux armes
tous les matins donc le gendarme breton
vient jeter un oeil au passage de
laurent
surveiller la frontière c'est l'une de
ses tâches
une autre consiste à contrôler les armes
des milices ou des policiers et si
possible de découvrir d'autres armes
cachées qui elles devront être détruits
toujours en bonne état d'ailleurs mais
qu'est ce que c'est comme arme
ces deux-là 47 cas si la reddition sans
gloire d'un des farouches mer rouge
ce week end s'est rendu aux gendarmes
français en expliquant qu'il avait été
entraîné par son frère dans la montagne
aujourd'hui mutilés il en a assez de
manquer de nourriture pour sa femme et
de médicaments pour son bébé alors il a
décidé de rendre les armes
favoriser ces retours découvrir les
armes dissuader des exactions les trois
tâches du gendarme breton et de ses
collègues
avec en prime la surveillance du site
d'angkor
ils sont donc ici observateurs du cessez
le feu contrôleur de police aux
démineurs
les soldats de la paix français vont
être bientôt 15 100 au cambodge
leurs missions sont différentes leur but
est unique d'abord maintenir la paix
ensuite restauré la confiance et enfin
permettent la tenue d'élections libres
en avril 93 les hommes sont
incorrigibles 131 chefs d'état et de
gouvernement ont décidé de se retrouver
demain à rio pour tenter de sauver une
terre qui s'abîme
mais ce sommet exceptionnel n'a même pas
commencé que l'on évoque déjà des
divergences entre le nord et le sud où
entre les etats-unis et les autres et
pourtant l'état de la planète est telle
qu'un consensus paraît indispensable
il suffit d'écouter le diagnostic du
docteur philippe denis lugubre
la terre n'est pas encore invivable mais
l'air y est déjà presque irrespirable
chaque année 6 milliards de tonnes de
carbone sont rejetées dans l'atmosphère
à qui la faute au bout d'échappement aux
activités industrielles des pays riches
bien sûr aux pays producteurs de pétrole
cette pollution à deux graves
conséquences d'abord elle réchauffe
sensiblement le climat de la planète
c'est l'effet de serre qui pourraient
faire monter le niveau des eaux
ensuite elle attaque la fameuse couche
d'ozone qui nous protège des
rayonnements ultraviolets autre soucis
dus à notre développement nous
produisons beaucoup déchets notamment
des déchets toxiques
ils proviennent surtout des pays riches
mais finit souvent par être exportés
vers les pays pauvres
nos océans sont des poubelles à cause
des marées noires mais surtout à cause
des déchets qui sont déversées pollution
au large pollution des côtes menace pour
toute la vie aquatique qui est un
élément essentiel de la chaîne
alimentaire les forêts ne se porte pas
mieux
ces zones vertes plus particulièrement
les forêts tropicales disparaissent à
une allure terrifiante l'homme coupent
les arbres pour faire commerce du bois
ou pour agrandir les terres cultivables
à chaque minute
l'équivalent de dix terrains de foot se
déboise pourtant la forêt joue un rôle
majeur pas seulement pour les peuples
qui en vivent
elle agit aussi sur le climat limite
l'érosion aujourd'hui elle fait place
nette au désert car les sols se dégrade
l'homme des friches trop irrigue mal les
terres deviennent stériles
combien de temps encore pourra-t-il se
nourrir chaque année 500 espèces
animales disparaissent à cause de la
chasse ou de la pollution
tous ces mots n'ont qu'un responsable
l'homme et la situation est d'autant
plus inquiétante que notre démographie
galopante
aujourd'hui la terre compte 5 milliard
et demi d'habitants
nos enfants seront sans doute 11
milliards en l'an 2000 150
c'est pour eux qu'il est urgent d'agir
pour l'heure légué en héritage autre
chose qu'un immense dépotoir
cet état est aggravée vous l'avez
compris par les fautes l'incompétence ou
l'insouciance des hommes exemple kerno
bill dominique dumas joseph tual nous
ont proposé hier leur premier reportage
sur les conséquences désastreuses de cet
accident nucléaire
les habitants de kiev et de la région
voudrait oublier cette catastrophe mais
le traumatisme est telle qu'ils en sont
incapables
reportage qui responsable de la
catastrophe de tchernobyl
victhom bloquera noble directeur de la
centrale en 86 déclaré coupable est
sorti de prison
usés après six ans de peine nous l'avons
retrouvée en famille dans la banlieue de
kiev
et pour la première fois il a accepté
d'être filmés et de parler une équipe de
télévision avant la catastrophe en 86
était-il conscient du danger
oui bien sûr je savais que je
travaillais dans quelque chose de
dangereux
mais à l'époque personne n'imaginait
qu'on en arriverait à une telle
situation
une telle tragédie sa personne ne
pouvait le prévoir selon les
informations que j'avais ça ne pouvait
pas se produire
déjà un premier accident en 1981 s'était
produit à l'époque c'était passé
inaperçu et des précautions avaient été
prises pour qu'une telle situation ne se
reproduise pas aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il ya encore des risques mais c'est
la tragédie de tout un système
visiblement victor voronov qui a repris
un travail la centrale peut considérer
avoir été un bouc émissaire de l'ancien
régime
la priorité maintenant d'aider les
personnes irradiées à la clinique du
centre de radiologie dans la banlieue de
kiev 300 patients peuvent être
accueillis ce longuement exposés sont
déjà morts mais à la clinique on reste
évasif sur le nombre de décès dû à
tchernobyl
officiellement une trentaine mais on
peut sûrement multiplier ce chiffre par
dix voire par sens si l'on considère les
leucémiques bord après trois ou quatre
ans régime de vitamines et surveillance
de la thyroïde constitue ici l'essentiel
et traitement nicolaï est un miraculé
ouvrier sur un chantier voisin il a été
exposé plusieurs minutes aux radiations
à quelques centaines de mètres du
réacteur 2 heures après l'explosion
alors maintenant comment se sentent ils
j'ai toujours des maux de tête et
également des problèmes de ratte et
également des problèmes aux jambes
ben ali parce taiana practice est ici
mais à kiev comme en ukraine parle t'on
encore de ces malades
signe des temps ce sixième anniversaire
de tchernobyl est presque passée
inaperçue
il est vrai que les préoccupations
économiques l'emportent ici sur les
problèmes écologiques et à vendin
conclure ce journal retour à roland
garros où les quatre demoiselles des
demi finales sont maintenant connus
alain dorgans nous les présente
sabbatini l'argent qui l'angoissé quand
ita martinez l'espagnol en pleine
confiance
l on parler la même langue sur le
central martinez 8e mondial a tout de
même semer le doute dans le jeu de
gabriella dirigeants le début du match à
sa guise 6 3 dans le premier set trois
jeux à rien dans le second sabbatini
semblait résigné l'argentine sortant de
sa torpeur et des parcours par la chance
à son tour aligné neuf jeux de rang
empochant le deuxième set 6 3 quand tu
ta martinez s'est à présent qu'elle a
laissé passer sa chance
ça va dit vie donne maintenant libre
cours à son talent et sa meilleure
couverture du court lui permet d'avoir
les deux pieds en demi finale
m
la différenciation de steffi graf
contraste avec l'humour grimaçante de
natalia sve rivard qui a encore en
mémoire la cuisante défaite enregistrée
à 1988 lors de sa finale face à
l'allemande 6-0 6-0 en 37 minutes
cette fois elle résistera 2h cave en
nous gratifiant même de point étonnant
malheureusement ce n'est pas encore
cette fois ci qu elle brisera
l'invincibilité de steffi graf garde le
cap dans ce tournoi toujours prête à
dégainer
après une interruption de près de quatre
heures provoquée par une pluie qui
tombait sans discontinuer
l'ouragan seles en bas de l'écran est
devenu cinglé la terre rouge et balayer
le tennis de jennifer capriati même
scénario dans les deux sets mené deux
jeux à rien seles a fait le plein des
jeux deux sets 6 2 6 2 aline petite
heure pour ces lettres qui donne de plus
en plus un sentiment de supériorité
arantxa sanchez viendra compléter le
dernier carré en venant à bout
facilement de la néerlandaise malongo
les gras et de six matches l'espagnol
marquera sa victoire en deux sets par l
élégance et sa pugnacité
on va proposer la candidature de dorgans
à l'académie française cinglé la terre
rouge
tomic champions comment se comportent
courir et bien courir continue sa
formidable marche en avant après avoir
remporté la première manche 6 2 il a
remporté 6 1 un deuxième mail à
retournement provisoire peut-être de
situation et bien c'est goran ivanisevic
qui mène 2 à 0 dans la troisième manche
le match du croate commence peut-être
métier merci dominique de toute façon
ceux qui aiment le tennis pourront vous
suivre après 20 heures juste après la
météo de michel touré qui prévoit des
orages terribles dans le sud écouté
attentivement ses prévisions donc tennis
après la météo avant la classe et tintin
le tintin du mardi soir puis soir 3 bien
sûr présenté comme chaque soir par marc
hautement bonne soirée sur l'a3 demain
19h bonsoir